écoutez le crime atroce du plus grand
des scélérats aviateurs et un avocat qui
du crime avait la bosse dans le vi a
bouleversé toute une localité de
puissants najaf ont-ils eu ce scélérat
consommé tu es des mouches tant qu'ils
pouvaient et même des oiseaux utile les
mâles et les femelles rien n'échappe à
ce cruel
non content de sanitaire dont il tient
un coût exact sur un carton qu'on trouve
un dans la boîte carnassière ce scélérat
une humain son attaque à l'être humain
pour tromper la bourgeoisie vêtu comme
un président il n'est un col d'astrakan
l'article de fantaisie info collant
selon bild église en oeuvre